starting out as a young chef my biggest
influence was definitely french cuisine
and when i was 23 years of age i was
determined to learn as much as i could
so i set off for paris to work in some
of the most demanding and exacting
kitchens
in the world and my passion and love for
french food
really took hold when i was living in
france i got to know two very distinct
traditions
of french food on the one hand there was
the delicious
oil cuisine i cooked all day in the
restaurant
and on the other hand there was the food
you ate in people's homes which is a lot
simpler to make
but still absolutely delicious my
ultimate french-inspired lunch
is very light bright and really takes me
back to when i lived in paris
it's my take on the salad nicoise serve
with a delicious goat's cheese
and pear tartine think of the nicoise as
an assembly job of delicious ingredients
brought together with a fantastic
dressing
the secret behind my salad nicoise is in
the dressing room
spoon dijon mustard into a pestle and
mortar
some people top the salad with anchovies
and capers but in mine
they're the base to the dressing we're
gonna grind that to a paste
and then get the garlic in there season
well with black pepper
it doesn't need any salt in there
because of the
anchovies add a couple of tablespoons of
red wine vinegar
olive oil and lastly flat leaf parsley
to give the dressing freshness against
those deep flavors
it's a thick rich substantial dressing
dressing done
now for the salad ball potatoes green
beans and eggs
from a rolling ball seven and a half to
eight minutes it should keep that nice
yolky creamy texture in the center once
the eggs are ready put them into cold
water to stop them cooking
and this is a great trick to peel them
so much easier peeling eggs when you use
the water that they've been cooling down
in
and the water will seep underneath all
the shell
so the whole shell just gets peeled off
of one
beautiful big layer now
beans
nice and crunchy season the beans and
potatoes whilst they're still
warm so they absorb more flavor a little
drizzle
of olive oil salt pepper
and just let them sit there whilst the
potatoes and beans cool down
i'm doing a simple french open sandwich
which is called a tartine
this is delicious first i'm toasting
baguette on the griddle
lightly oil your griddle pan get your
bread
stick it on there take a pear
it goes brilliantly well with goat's
cheese slice the pear
into finger width pieces
that's the color we're looking for that
dark
crispy texture now for the ghost cheese
give it a season it doesn't need salt
because a little fresh goat cheese is
already
quite salty then a handful of crumbled
walnuts
they go under the grill whilst they put
the tuna and these ones together
my secret to assembling a great nisswa
salad is to start in the middle of the
plate
and add ingredients layer by layer
there's one thing i'm always missing the
bottom of salad is dressing
so i like to put it on the plate first
baby gem lettuce is great because it's
robust
and holds that heavy dressing then add
firm waxy salad potatoes and green beans
i like them to have a bit of a crunch
canned tuna can be fantastic i'm using a
good quality one in olive oil which has
been drained
next baby plum tomatoes which have a
lovely intense sweet flavor
and then my eggs that nice
dark rich yolk beautiful
yolk's still creamy inside
he's a little olive nicoise this will
work just as well with other black
olives
and then your dressing drizzle that
round gently
beautiful that is a nicoise
in heaven now tartine
wow just a smell of those grilled
walnuts
that is beautiful a simple
but very elegant tuna nicoise
with a delicious ghost cheese sandwich
wonderful
[Music]
my vibrant and gutsy nisswa salad with
that incredible anchovy and caper
dressing
served with a pear and goat's cheese
tartine too good
to let the french keep all to themselves
[Music]
tilly would you mind helping daddy with
the
chicken fricassee please we're gonna
start off
with browning all
the chicken off nicely pan on get that
nice and hot
what i want you to do for me first is to
season
the chicken with salt and pepper please
thank you
so that's on one side then we turn the
chicken over
so we season it on the other side salt
good girl
and pepper nice now this is almost like
a chicken
stew okay what's that there
[Music]
time time good girl what's that one
there
that one that's right rosemary and
because this is quite a rustic
french dish we don't need to chop
everything
so you get the garlic and you just bash
it like that
now smell mmm that's right
so that's nice and hot put a tablespoon
of olive oil in there a couple of lugs
one two good girl put the chicken in it
and you lay away you're like nice and
brown i'm getting good at this
you are skin side down
so we got the color on the skin now just
want you to cut the mushrooms in half
the belly please okay
these are chestnut mushrooms there are
lots of different kinds of mushrooms out
there there are lots and lots of
different types of mushrooms
which one's your favorite one of my
favorites is the
giro mushroom i like mushrooms that are
a bit bigger than this and
um some dinners with mum we cut out the
middle
put pesto and cheese in it and then we
bake them uh-uh
i want you to sprinkle the pancetta over
the chicken please
good girl nice mushrooms
not yet because i'm gonna get some color
on the chicken first
okay and
as that pancetta starts to cook down
it puts a really nice flavor on the
chicken
yeah so we're sort of sauteing
everything okay all right garlic in
please
good girl just throw them in and i want
you to sprinkle the mushrooms on top of
that
good girl and then there's the rosemary
you can get your fingers like that and
you pull it down
you take it all off hold it
put it down good girl so now you've got
the nice little rosemary sprigs
and we do the same with the thyme now
the time flower is a little bit smaller
what different flavors do they give so
the time is a little bit sweeter
okay and the rosemary a little bit more
savoury
which one do you like i like them both
because they both get a nice smell
don't they so they leaf in i'd like you
to put that rosemary
and thyme in there please
lovely sprinkle it over right i'd like
you to stand back now because i'm gonna
flambe this
i do not want to get those little
slippers caught on fire what are the
names
rumpel and judy julia nice
okay great ready yeah
in with a brandy and then just tilt the
pan gently
whoa whoa how cool is that magical
beautiful bit like a cauldron all the
cognac
has been flambe so there's no raw
alcohol
anywhere so we've got a really nice deep
rich flavor
i'm gonna add my chicken stock you know
rampo likes that not my slipper rumple
run for the dog ah rumple the dog well
he likes chicken stock
yes when he's a good boy he gets um he
gets it in his um
with his biscuit it's gone in like wow
really quickly
simmer and reduce the stock for around
10 minutes
now we're going to cook the most amazing
potatoes
soda potatoes are really simple to make
and absolutely delicious
start by slicing the potatoes into
finger whipped pieces
then parboil them for five to six
minutes
when you cook something like rosemary or
thyme or basil
does it slowly let off the flavor into
the bottle
very much so in a hot pan
add a tablespoon of goose fat and saute
the potatoes until they turn
golden and add in shallots garlic
rosemary
and thyme that goes in
over top and that goose fat now is
starting to fry
the potatoes you just leave that sat
there
to complete my ultimate french dinner my
version of a classic
a glorious lavender creme caramel for
dessert
the first job is the lavender sugar you
can buy this ready-made or simply add
dried edible sprigs of lavender to
caster sugar and store
you can also try this trick with vanilla
pods and cinnamon
to bring new subtle flavors to sweets
and bacon
[Music]
for the creme caramel melt plain caster
sugar until it turns dark golden
pour into ramekins sprinkle with
lavender flowers
and cool now to make a simple custard
gently heat whole milk in a pan until
steaming
meanwhile whisk together egg vanilla
seeds and lavender sugar
until golden and fluffy then gradually
pour the hot milk
into the mix whisking continuously until
the custard is smooth
and creamy to set cook in a water bath
or bamboo
a good tip is to line a roasting tin
with a cloth to stop the ramekins
jiggling around pour your custard
then boiling water around the ramekins
until halfway
up the sides then cook in a preheated
oven
for around 30 minutes until set cool in
the fridge
then when you're ready to serve dip the
ramekins in hot water to loosen the
creme caramel
[Music]
ebola lavender clean caramel
[Music]
look at that chicken now so i'm just
going to
turn the gas right down and put the lid
on
just like that but leave a little bit so
it can net out some stuff so i can let
out some steam that's right
now what i'd like to do is to chop daddy
some parsley crunch it up nicely
tuck your fingers in and take your time
[Music]
now my hands have got lots of different
flavors all those wonderful flavors
you could almost be french
sprinkle that on there good girl
nice messy buckle
nice now potato chicken
i can tell jack's gonna love this is he
looks delish doesn't it smells
i delicious smell that even before you
took the lid off let's get on my darling
good job by the way thank you i can't
wait for the others to try it i hope
they
love it this is my ultimate french
dinner
chicken fricassee with sensational
herbie sauty potatoes
and lavender creme caramel